father
visitor was not pleased
hey everyone is Peter Brown standing in
for freelancer Daniel Starkey for their
review of Warhammer 40,000 Dawn of War 3
Donal war 3 is a game at odds with
itself matches start with a lot of
momentum and expand quickly before
settling into a soft balance for long
stretches careful control of elite
warriors on the frontlines is essential
but so is constantly nurturing your base
and marshaling upgrades for your armies
despite that Donna war 3 holds its own
offering up delicious tooth and nail
fights that will push both your
technical skill and strategic aptitude
to their limit like most games under the
Warhammer umbrella Donna war 3 isn't
that friendly to newcomers and it
actually matters this time around
everything from tactical options to unit
tactics means at least partially on
knowledge of the Warhammer universe the
tutorial will do a solid job of giving
you the tools you need to get going but
background knowledge is all but
essential beyond a healthy addition to
the already massive Warhammer canon the
single-player campaign doesn't offer
much each of its 17 missions serve as a
drawn-out tutorial and that's ok on its
own but without interesting twists on
the fundamentals of play you're better
off starting with multiplayer online
skirmishes can have between 2 and 6
human or AI players split into two teams
each is charged with defending a
powerful both sides start with an array
of basic defences and from there you'll
plan out your base and capture strategic
points around the map - pulling
resources and keep tabs on the enemy
that in itself could form the backbone
of the game but dawn of war 3 also has
an array of powerful hero units each is
a pillar of the Warhammer story and
comes with weapons and powers befitting
their esteem
we've completed a power generator
while most elite says they're called can
turn the time on their own they're akin
to a queen and chess and that if you do
manage to lose one it can be devastating
what this means practically speaking is
that just as your base building gets
more complex and requires more care and
attention
you're also tasked with tactically
managing your elite units that makes for
one steep learning curve but for those
that manage it there's a lot of added
depth overall there's an unusual
attentiveness to the frontlines which
lends itself to white-knuckle play
pressing with the gargantuan elite as a
distraction right as you capture a
resource node is exhilarating and made
that much better when it results in
activating a means to warp in
reinforcements from across the map these
gains are always tenuous though Donna
voir strictly limits army size and
resource gathering slows exponentially
with the more troops you gain this means
that even if you knock an opponent down
they'll build up resources quickly and
come back swinging in short order that
magnifies the importance of
psychological play running with the
previous example while you'd have a
strong forward position that also
stretches supply lines and leaves you
open to a swift brutal counter-attack
these quick reversals are brilliant and
make for intense memorable matches while
humans are far more fun to spar with the
included AI isn't a slouch they will try
their own tricks often hinting at larger
enemies than they actually have if only
to intimidate you and launch a sneak
attack to your core base each of the
three main factions also compliment one
another well in the classic
rock-paper-scissors fashion Space
Marines are slow to build up momentum
but once they hit the field they're a
force elder are mobile and suited for
hit and run attacks in the orcs well
they're weird they are exceptionally
strong but only when they admit a
war-cry which while terrifying notifies
everyone in the field to put their
garden in the middle of matches you can
tune your army a bit changing out
different elite units as a kind of
lowdown in a nod to its tabletop
inspirations you can also customize the
paint and color scheme for every unit in
the game given the role of army
customization to war hammer proper it's
a shame you can't also swap out weapons
and gear for your basic units and
vehicles the options given help mix
things up a bit but they're also a bit
shell and a few other problems lurk here
and there particularly in the user
interface
on multiple occasions elite units
wouldn't deselect when clicking around
the map at times dragging boxes around
troops wouldn't highlight them at all
while small problems on the whole they
did cause their share of raised voices
Dawn of War 3 certainly sounds amazing
with crisp sound effects and an
excellent soundtrack but unfortunately
the visual presentation leaves something
to be desired battles often look great
zoomed out but pulling in shows plenty
of blemishes the camera also doesn't do
a good job of showing off the
battlefield even at its most distant
very little of the map fits on the
screen meaning that you can expect to
need to move around a lot during play an
odd chimera of its forebears there's a
lot in this fast-paced RTS that is just
a little bit off parts of the interface
don't work sometimes inter match army
management feels half-baked and
micromanagement needed to use the game's
signature hero units effectively doesn't
jive with the extensive base building
you need to support them even so dawn of
war 3 is a rare strategy game that keeps
the adrenaline pumping throughout
you